en el vídeo anterior encontramos la
pendiente en un punto de la curva de la
equis cuadrada pero ahora vamos a ver si
podemos generalizar o encontrar una
fórmula donde nos dé la pendiente en
cualquier punto de esta curva llegó a la
equis cuadrada así que permíteme
redibujar mi función aquí nunca está de
más tener un bonito dibujo
ese es mi eje y este es mi eje x
y mi curva está así
ya lo han visto varias veces este es
igual a equis cuadrada así que ahora
vamos a hacer las cosas muy generales y
de hecho vamos a escribir la definición
de nuestra derivada si tenemos un punto
aquí que le llamamos x es un punto
general y queremos encontrar la
pendiente en ese punto del valor de x
queremos encontrar la función donde si
ustedes me dan una x yo pueda encontrar
la pendiente en ese punto x y a esa
función le vamos a llamar f prima de x
esta va a ser la derivada la derivada de
fx
recordemos que f es una función en donde
si yo le doy un valor de x me va a
regresar otro valor y cuando yo podemos
dibujar esta curva de acá en f prima de
x tenemos la misma equis pero en lugar
de tener un punto de la curva vamos a
tener la pendiente en ese valor de x que
corresponde a el valor de la función x
en ese punto
aquí si ponemos un valor en la x vamos a
recibir el valor de la pendiente en ese
punto si escribimos un 3 aquí el valor
que vamos a recibir va a ser un 6 esto
lo vimos en el vídeo anterior y en el
vídeo anterior vimos que vamos a
expresar f prima de x como la pendiente
de la línea secante entre este punto x y
otro punto que está un poquito más
alejado de éste así que la pendiente
bien la salida secante es el valor de ye
que corresponde al punto que está un
poco más alejado de este punto x
efe
x + h - el valor de jane que corresponde
a este punto x este de aquí es f x menos
fx esto de arriba es la diferencia en el
cambio engine y esto tiene que estar
dividido entre el cambio en x este punto
más alejado x + h menos este valor x
esta distancia esa diferencia es h es la
pendiente de la línea que une estos dos
puntos y lo que comentamos es que
podíamos tomar el límite cuando h tiende
0 para encontrar la pendiente de la
línea tangente en el punto x que es mi
punto de interés y bueno ya que
repasamos todo esto vamos a aplicar esta
idea a una función en particular que es
en este caso nuestra ye igual a x
cuadrada podemos considerar este punto
con las coordenadas x como x cuadrada ya
que fx es igual a de x cuadrada y este
otro va a ser el punto vamos a ponerlo
en otro color estas coordenadas serán x
+ h
el punto en x en el eje x coma el valor
en ya que es x + h al cuadrado en el
vídeo anterior hicimos el ejemplo usando
una x en particular que era igual a 3
pero ahora vamos a usarlo de manera
general si ustedes me dan cualquier
valor de x yo les podría decir cuál es
la pendiente exactamente en ese punto si
ustedes me dan un -3 yo les puedo decir
cuál es la pendiente en ese punto de x
igual a menos 3 así que vamos a
aplicarlo aquí queremos encontrar el
cambio de g entre el cambio de x o la
diferencia en x antes que nada el cambio
en g
es la parte de esta coordenada eso que
estoy subrayando aquí x + h al cuadrado
que es el valor de esta x + h en la
función el valor en que recordamos que
es igual a x cuadrado por lo tanto este
valor va a ser igual a x + h al cuadrado
y con ambas coordenadas obtengo este
valor en la curva lo mismo sucede aquí
abajo cuando tengo mi valor de x mi
valor en el eje y va a ser x al cuadrado
y sé que se está complicando un poquito
en el dibujo pero aquí lo pongo en otro
color
así que esto es igual a menos x al
cuadrado mi diferencia
y para relacionarlo con nuestra
definición de la derivada esta parte de
azul
así que violente a esta otra parte que
estoy subrayando aquí simplemente la
evaluamos en nuestra función
esta es nuestra fx igual a equis
cuadrada
simplemente lo evaluamos cuando x es
igual a x + h si pusieras yo una aquí
sería al cuadrado si pusieron la manzana
aquí sería una manzana al cuadrado así
que esto corresponde a esto otro y esta
parte de aquí corresponde a esta x
cuadrada entonces de nuevo este es
nuestra diferencia en ye y ahora la
vamos a dividir entre nuestra diferencia
en x
x + h - x o lo que es lo mismo h
nuestro cambio en x es h y recordamos
este es la pendiente de la línea que une
32 puntos pero lo que queremos encontrar
es el límite conforme se va reduciendo
la distancia entre estos dos puntos
hasta que nuestra línea se convierte en
una línea tangente por lo que es el
límite cuando h tiende a cero y esto va
a ser igual a nuestra f prima de x y
esto es exactamente la misma definición
de acaso lo que adecuándola a una
función en particular este era para
cualquier función y aquí conocemos cuál
es la función de esta curva en este caso
que fx es igual a x al cuadrado y eso lo
aplicamos
y ahora veamos si podemos evaluar este
límite así que esto va a ser igual al
límite bueno lo escribir mejor al límite
cuando h tiende a cero
y esto vamos a elevarlo al cuadrado
x al cuadrado más 2 x x por h más al
cuadrado
- esta x cuadrada - x cuadrada y todo
esto lo vamos a dividir entre h
vamos a hacer un poco más de espacio
para simplificar esto
esta x cuadrada - x cuadrada se anulan
y podemos dividir el numerador entre el
denominador de manera que nos queda
efe prima de x igual
2x h / h nos queda 2x y se me estaba
olvidando escribir lo del límite que eso
es muy importante el límite cuando h
tiende 0 ahora si de estos 22 x
h cuadrante h queda h
y si se acuerdan del vídeo anterior
cuando hicimos esto para una equis en
particular cuando x era igual a 3 nos
quedó 6 + delta x
recordemos que delta x es exactamente lo
mismo que esta h si aplicamos el límite
cuando tiene 0 nos va a quedar que esto
es igual a 2x así que acabamos de
encontrar que si tenemos esta fx y ese
es un muy buen resultado es emocionante
7x es igual a equis cuadrada la derivada
f prima de x va a ser igual a esto 2x y
quiero asegurarme de que ustedes sepan
cómo interpretar esto en fx y ustedes me
dan un valor de x yo les voy a decir el
valor de la función en ese punto
en cambio en f prima de x yo les voy a
decir la pendiente en ese punto y vamos
a dibujarlo para que quede todavía aún
más claro vamos a tratar de visualizar
una función que es la pendiente de otra
función en un punto éste
es mi eje
y este otro este es mi eje
efe este es mi eje x y vamos a dibujar
esta función
esta es la curva de mi función f x
que es igual a equis cuadrada
y bueno recordamos si ustedes me dan un
punto en el eje x el punto 7 lo
sustituya que sacó el cuadrado y obtengo
el valor en que será 49 y la coordenada
edad de este punto es 7,49 hasta aquí no
hay nada nuevo estamos trabajando con
funciones y ahora cuál será f prima de 7
que f prima de x es 2 por x así que 2
por 7 14 qué significa
bueno esta es la pendiente de la línea
tangente a este punto de x 7 así que si
yo tomo este punto y le dibujar una
línea tangente más o menos así que
apenas roce nuestra curva no me quedo
bonita vamos a dibujar la mejor el
cambio de eje entre el cambio en x sería
igual a 14
esta es la pendiente
y vemos que es una pendiente bastante
alta si quisiéramos encontrar la
pendiente de este punto que digamos es
no sé
x
es igual a 2 si x es igual a 2 la
pendiente aquí será f prima de 2
igualados por 2 va a ser igual a 4 va a
ser una pendiente mucho más suave la
pendiente es 4 m de pendiente es igual a
4 cuál será la pendiente de mi x igual a
sabemos que es f de 00 al cuadrado es
sigue siendo 0 es re prima de 0 que va a
ser aquí a bueno 2 x 0 pues también va a
ser cero así que aquí no saber pendiente
la pendiente es igual a cero esta es mi
línea tangente que coincide con el eje y
no tiene ninguna pendiente lo cual se ve
bastante lógico de que la línea tangente
a nuestro punto de la curva cuando x es
igual a cero sea una línea horizontal
vamos a probar otro valor ahora el punto
va a ser menos
menos -1 así qué efe - 1 es igual a x al
cuadrado 1 al cuadrado es igual a 1
aquí más o menos y efe prima de menos
uno va a ser 2 x x 2 x menos 1 me queda
menos 2
y eso significa que es una pendiente
negativa cuando x es igual a 1 la
pendiente de la tangente en ese punto de
la curva va a ser negativa -1 este es mi
tangente y es una pendiente que va hacia
abajo tiene sentido la pendiente aquí la
pendiente es igual a menos 2